okay welcome to a new video I'm this
actually the second game I played today
and the first one I recorded but I won't
put on the channel because it was one of
those silly time only winsor alright so
we got dumb rule or pass exchange here
and I'm played some line that I didn't
really intend it to play two bit silly
actually what I did them okay of course
this is just the main line or one main
line of them of the exchange so the Rue
La Paz exchange but it's not I'm sorry a
line that I i usually play I was still
um yeah but unsettled by the last game
because I simply don't get why people
play dead drawn and games on time in an
online blitz game which has absolutely
no relevance whatsoever I mean it's not
like they're fighting for use team
result or or money or anything that that
might um yeah give you the incentive to
to to play i'm completely useless
position on time but um yeah I guess you
really can't them expect them except
more than this kind of behavior okay so
um we have the ruler pass exchange here
and yeah it's kind of a typical position
like Scott's two bishops white has the
better structure and got a knight on d5
yeah I don't want to take the night
really because I
it would give away the bishop power I'd
like to do is if possible play g 6 + f5
opening up the position I mean f5 or so
maybe maybe a dream if you go so with 92
g 3 yeah this is not the so surprising
to me hmm ok I was I'm a bit surprised
that he played this way but ok night
night to e6 also i'm also an EDM
now not not a better DM so maybe I
should should go here pre 1986 other e6
and maybe prepare moves like f5 or h5 I
need to be cautious of course because
this bitter bond is heaven is just in
how
okay so i will try to open up this now
here very a strange move I think and now
g5 isn't this just so just opening the
position on white skin now maybe I'm
overlooking something here but f3 is
just just hanging now okay if I take
with the rook what's the big deal here
don't get it really okay I'm taking here
and also have this move here
okay if I take on g6 now he has this
night x b6 idea so I'm not sure if I if
I should do that if i play c6 what what
is he playing this III bishop is some
also a liability don't know what is
playing actually removes the night I'm
just capturing III
and I don't see how he should attack one
of my pieces to play some sort of
counter to check him don't see it
everything's protected here next move I
think I just win apiece maybe I'm I'm
overlooking something no night also
hanging now so it doesn't have time for
King f2 or something it's just a piece
so I'm like takes c3 now
don't see the point two pieces Bishop c7
yeah everything wins basically I'm just
two pieces up
I look at fado
alright
yeah I'm just blocking this so I'm
really no I don't see what what you
should do here
just grab me five rupees 707 also yeah I
mean this kind of position is not not
quite sure maybe around equal it's
always hard to tell but I think I have
some counter play on the Kings side but
this this h4 h5 now I'm not sure not
sure what he what she was planning there
maybe you overlooked this move but it's
pretty clear that i want to want to open
up the position quickly i mean even
taken with the pawn wouldn't be wouldn't
be terrible King f2f five and I'm just
attacking with my bishops um so H voice
weird move i think on h5 you should have
h three to keep the the structure on the
King side I'm intact and here on it's
already already am a bit tricky so I
actually and now you see them the
evaluation yet somehow this is set up
differently uh-huh I need to need to
check this if I if I if I use the engine
after the game uh-huh weird maybe the
kind of window set up here so Bishop 93
seems to still keep keep White's
position together but now it's it's it's
just terrible with with f3 going away
yeah right thanks for watching and yes
you soon in the new one and play a
couple of blitz games today